shots and secretary baser will provide
an update on our work to address the
long-term impacts of covet
first i want to discuss where we stand
on funding for the covet 19 response
we've made tremendous progress in our
fight against the virus we have 217
million americans fully vaccinated
two out of three eligible adults boosted
a medicine cabinet full of highly
effective treatments
and convenient tests
but as we've made clear for months
there's more work to do
the country urgently needs additional
funding from congress to continue our
fight against coven
the administration requested emergency
funds to ensure our medical tools
like vaccines treatments and tests
remain readily available to the american
people
and importantly funding for our global
response so we can get more shots and
arms around the world
we are encouraged by the senate's work
on a bipartisan plan
to help meet some of our most immediate
domestic needs
but as we've made clear we need more for
our domestic response to stay up to date
on vaccines
to procure monoclonal antibody
treatments and antiviral pills
to provide protection for the immuno
compromise
and to sustain
our testing capacity
and it is a real disappointment that
there's no global funding in this bill
this virus knows no borders and it's in
our national interest to vaccinate the
world and protect against possible new
variants without additional funding for
our global response
we won't have resources to help get more
shots in arms in countries in need
we will lack funding to provide oxygen
and other life-saving supplies
and our global genomic sequencing
capabilities will fall off
and undermine our ability to detect any
emerging variants around the world
as we know this virus is unpredictable
time is of the essence so we urge
congress to move promptly
on the 10 billion emergency funding
package developed in the senate
the bill is a start
it should pass immediately but it's
exactly that just to start
congress must keep working to
immediately provide additional funding
for our remaining domestic needs
so that we're prepared for whatever
comes
and importantly to act with urgency to
fund our global covet 19 response
so that we can accelerate our efforts to
turn vaccines into vaccinations
around the world
as we work with congress to fund our
global response
we will continue doing all we can to
vaccinate the world
at president biden's direction we've
done more than just lead the global
vaccination effort
we have pioneered the global vaccination
effort
the us was the first country in the
world to donate a significant amount of
our own vaccine supply
creating the model for other countries
to do the same
the u.s was the first country to strike
a deal with a major vaccine manufacturer
to purchase doses solely to donate to
other countries in need
one billion pfizer vaccine doses
we were the first and remain the only
country to broker a deal
with the u.s manufacturer and kovacs to
get vaccines into humanitarian zones to
reach people
displaced by war famine and other crises
and we were the first and are still the
only country to give up our place in
line for delivery of doses
enabling the african union to more
quickly access over a hundred million
modern vaccine doses
today we're adding to our list of firsts
announcing that we will be the first
nation to donate tens of millions of
pediatric covered 19 vaccines to low and
lower middle income countries
for free with no strings attached
these countries around the world are
eager to get these doses in fact
more than 20 low and lower middle income
countries have approached the united
states asking us to provide vaccines for
their young children
we're now ready to answer their call
it's the right thing to do
the u.s has now delivered over half
billion adult vaccines to 114
different
countries and because of president
biden's leadership vaccine supply is no
longer the constraint to getting shots
and arms around the world
in fact countries need funding and
assistance to turn vaccines into
vaccinations
that's why congress must step up and
provide critical funding to help
countries in need get shots into arms
in the meantime any low and lower middle
income country
that wants adult doses from the us can
get those doses
again for free with no strings attached
and now with more than enough supply for
adults we're working with advisor to
make pediatric doses available to donate
as part of our ongoing commitment to
donate 1.2 billion vaccines
thanks to this historic action children
in countries most in need will soon have
access to safe
effective
vaccines and parents will gain the peace
of mind that their children are
protected
again this virus knows no borders so
getting more people vaccinated
is one of the best ways to protect
people here at home
and around the world
and today we're making clear the us will
continue to lead and pioneer the global
effort to get both adults and children
vaccinated
with that i'll turn it over to dr
wolinski dr welinski
thank you jeff and good afternoon
everyone let's walk start by walking
through today's data the current
seven-day daily average of cases is
about 25 000 cases per day a decrease
nationally of about four percent over
the previous week and remains relatively
stable over the past few weeks
the seven day average of hospital
admissions is about 1400 per day a
decrease of about 17 percent over the
previous week and the seven day average
daily deaths are about 570 per day which
is a decrease of nearly 16
over the prior week
new national estimates released today
show the omicron sub-lineage v82
indicated by light pink in this u.s map
by hhs regions
is now projected to account for 72
percent of circulating variants
nationally with all regions of the
country reporting that ba2 is now the
dominant variant as we've previously
shared about the ba2 variant there is no
evidence that ba2 results in more severe
disease compared with the ba1 variant
nor does it appear to be more likely to
evade immune protection than ba1 but ba2
does appear to be more transmissible
than ba1
the high level of immunity in the
population from vaccines boosters and
previous infection will provide some
level of protection against va ii
however we strongly encourage everyone
to be up to date on their cova 19
vaccines
looking across the country we see that
95 percent of counties are reporting low
coven 19 community levels which
represents over 97 percent of the us
population
if we look more closely at the local
level we find a handful of counties
where we are seeing increases in both
cases and markers of more severe disease
like hospitalizations and inpatient bed
capacity which have resulted in an
increased cover 19 community level in
some areas
while on the national level cases remain
relatively low compared to prior points
in the pandemic we continue to look to
coven 19 community levels which were
developed to work locally at the county
level
as we move forward we encourage local
jurisdictions to closely monitor their
own covet 19 community levels and to
follow additional metrics that are
that they may have available as leading
indicators of disease for example
wastewater and syndromic surveillance
it's important for communities and
health officials to use these measures
to help inform prevention strategies for
their local area like masking testing
and plans for treatment should they move
into higher cover 19 community levels
now as we continue to closely monitor
kova 19 in the united states we're
reminded of the critical need to have a
sustainable and resilient public health
workforce in place that can effectively
respond to both emerging threats and
ongoing public health needs
during the decade prior to covet 19 the
public health workforce lost an
estimated 60 000 jobs nationwide despite
the continued demands to respond to
multiple chronic public health threats
like h1n1 zika and ebola
as we look to building back this much
needed workforce we must prioritize a
public health workforce that is as
diverse as the communities they serve
culturally competent and equipped with
skills to meet the public health needs
of communities across the nation
one way we're working to build this
workforce is through public health
americorps a groundbreaking initiative
that supports the recruitment training
and development of our nation's next
generation of public health leaders
public health americorps is supported
through investments from the american
rescue plan and is anticipated to fund
up to 5 000 positions over the next five
years
this week americorps will award over 80
grants to the first round of public
health americorps programs across 32
states and territories that will allow
the recruitment of nearly 3 000 public
health americorps members
the work of these initial members will
help to address public health needs in
our nation's inner cities to build
tribal public health capacity to address
dress health disparities in rural
america and to bolster public health
resources in our u.s territories
recruitment training and development of
public health personnel is a key part of
building our nation's public health
workforce allowing us to better respond
to current and future public health
threats
and now i will turn it over to dr pouchy
dr fauci thank you very much dr wolenski
i would like to now discuss the covert
19 boosters particularly in the context
of the fourth dose of an mrna boost
let's take a very quick update and
overview of the situation that we're in
right now
so several studies have shown
that covert 19 vaccine booster shots
protect against serious illness
hospitalizations and even death that's a
well-established fact now and the cdc
recommends everyone aged 12 and older to
receive a covert 19 vaccine booster
after completing their primary
vaccination series
and certain individuals can now receive
two boasted booster doses people who are
moderately or severely immune
compromised
as well as adults 50 years of age or
older next slide
and as we know on march 29th the fda
authorized
second booster doses of two covet 19
vaccines for older and immunocompromised
individuals and the cdc recommend that
same day
that additional gloss boosters can now
be used for certain individuals let's
take a look at the data behind those
decisions
so
the first deuce the first booster doses
restore the waning vaccine effectiveness
of a primary vaccine series including
against severe disease
the effectiveness of the first booster
dose we know wanes
over time
and growing evidence indicates that a
second covert 19 dose can restore
vaccine effectiveness for certain
populations
and albeit the data now at least for the
short term
and we look forward to longer term data
next slide
so let's take a look at some of the
israeli studies there are a few of them
that are really quite telling one from
bar on
looking at more than one million people
who are age 60 or older and eligible for
the fourth dose
and in that look at in that study
an additional booster dose of the fisa
product at four months
resulted in a two-fold lower rate of
confirmed infection
and a 4.3 fold lower rate of severe
illness
in another study next slide again from
israel by
uh
whatever it is by our bell
about a half a million members of a
health services group again age 60 years
of age or older
and now during an omicron surge
individuals who received a second
booster dose of the fisa product at four
months had a 78 reduction in death
compared to those who received only
the first boost
and on the next slide this is rather
dramatically shown
by this kaplan-meier shot
where you see here in the pink red the
first booster namely a third dose and
then in the lighter blue color you look
at the mortality rate of individuals who
receive the second booster or
the fourth dose next slide
and yet again in another study by
gazette in almost a hundred thousand
people had a different health care
service
when you looked at the fourth dose and
compared it to the third dose there was
an 86 percent vaccine effectiveness
against severe disease next slide
now what we're doing at the nih looking
forward
about fourth doses that might be
available for people in the longer range
we want to do better than just what we
have so there's now a new study that we
just recently launched called covale and
what we'll be doing is assessing
different fourth doses
that are either ancestral strain
or variance specific in the first phase
of the study
in the second phase of the study we're
planning on looking at different vaccine
platforms for the purpose of getting a
great durability than we currently have
next slide
and let me close by again just bringing
to the attention of the audience
covid.gov where we can get one-stop
shopping of all the information that you
will need to help you navigate decisions
about vaccines and about testings with
that i'll hand it over now to secretary
becerra
thank you dr fauci
when it comes to covid we have more
tools than ever before to stay safe
from vaccines and boosters to treatments
and tests all widely available and no
cost to the american people thanks to
our national coveted response over the
past year
but we also know that many people
continue to feel the physical and the
mental burden of this pandemic
we have to ensure that people with
disabilities older americans and people
who are immunocompromised aren't left
behind
and that they continue to have the tools
and resources that they need to stay
safe
just yesterday we expanded coverage of
free over-the-counter cova tests to the
tens of millions of medicare
beneficiaries
people with medicare now have access
each month to up to eight easy to use at
home covet 19 tests at no cost
this is all part of our overall strategy
to ensure access to tests free of charge
in the past year we have more than
tripled the number of sites where people
can get kova 19 tests for free and
delivered close to 250 million free
at-home rapid tests to americans who
have ordered them
president biden has been clear
we must ensure that no one is left
behind as we work to move forward in the
fight against kova 19.
that also means taking on big and
complex physical mental health
challenges caused by covet
americans of every age and background
are experiencing long covet americans
have experienced the loss of a loved one
due to covet including over 200 000
children who've lost a parent or
caregiver
and americans nationwide are grappling
with mental health and substance use
challenges caused by or exacerbated by
the pandemic
let's be clear
we are going to use every tool we have
to be there for these americans
we've made significant investments in
mental health care as well as substance
use prevention treatment and recovery
support
that is especially important for people
dealing with covet and coveted related
laws
we've launched efforts across the nih
the cdc and the veterans veterans
administration including the landmark
1.1 billion dollar recovery recovery
initiative to better understand long
covet and accelerate scientific progress
and we are providing americans
experiencing long covert information
about where they can access the
resources the support they need as well
as helping them understand if they have
a disability and educating them on their
rights
wankovid is real
and there is still so much we don't know
about it
millions of americans may be struggling
with lingering health effects ranging
from things that are easier to notice
like troubling trouble breathing or
irregular heartbeats to less apparent
but potentially serious conditions
related to the brain or mental health
at the president's direction the
department of health and human services
will be leading a government-wide
response to long covid focused on three
main goals
improving care services and other
support for individuals with long covert
enhancing education and outreach among
the public private sector and the
medical community
and advancing research to support both
goals
and of course we'll collaborate with
academic industry and state and local
partners to better understand long cobit
through it all
we'll continue to assess and highlight
the long-term effects of covet 19 on our
hardest hit and highest-risk communities
and make sure they receive the support
they need to do this we're launching the
first ever interagency national research
agenda on long covet a national research
action plan
hhs will lead a government-wide
interagency coordinating council which
will involve experts from the department
of defense
veterans administration the labor
department and many entities across
government to coordinate both public and
private sector work to advance our
understanding of long covet and to
accelerate efforts to prevent detect and
treat it
in real time we will share lessons on
how to prevent detect and treat long
covet and this coordinated effort will
help ensure our research is being
directed toward the people who need care
the most
we continue to focus on improving care
if we receive additional financial
support for it from congress we will
launch new centers of excellence in
communities across the country to
provide high quality care to individuals
experiencing lawn cover and to get best
practices out there to physicians across
the country
we're determined as a nation as the
president has said to not leave anyone
behind
and that includes our loved ones
suffering from long covet and related
conditions
we see you we are focused on you and we
are committed to advancing our nation's
capacity to understand and treat your
conditions
and i'll end with this
we know the best way to prevent long
covet is to prevent you from getting
coveted in the first place
that's why it's so critical to get
vaccinated and boosted which is our best
tools that we have to prevent covet 19.
so i continue to encourage everyone
eligible to get vaccinated and boosted
to go do it so we can all move forward
safely together
thanks back to you jeff
well thanks secretary with that uh kevin
let's open it up for some questions
kevin
thanks jeff we only have time for a few
questions today let's go to sabrina
siddiki at wall street journal
thank you as always for doing the
briefing i want to ask about covered
funding
republicans are trying to insert an
amendment into the covid deal
to reinstate title 42 there are even
some democrats such as arizona senator
mark kelly who said that they're open to
considering such an amendment is the
administration concerned that the
decision to lift title 42 could now
threaten covet funding
thanks for the question
title 42 is a public health authority
and therefore it's always been a
decision made by the scientists
and public health experts at the cdc
and it's based on the public health
conditions and it should remain
independent
of the urgently needed funding that we
talked about today to sustain our
coveted response here domestically and
our global response so this should not
be included on any funding bill
the decision should be made by cdc uh
which it has been and that's where it
belongs next question please
go to aaron billups at spectrum news
hi thanks so much for taking my uh
question um for dr wolinski and
secretary becerra just wondering with
this increased focus on lone covert
covid if type 2 diabetes is being
considered a part of the long covered
problem there was a new study published
in the lens set last month that finds a
link between
covet infections and an increased risk
of being diagnosed with diabetes and
experts i've spoken to say there's an
urgent need to aggressively screen the
u.s population for diabetes
and get more people into diabetes
management programs uh are you looking
for funding for that as well have
there's been any uh discussions about
that
dr wolinski why don't you go first here
yeah
thank you for that question first let me
say we the science is definitely
starting to demonstrate this link
between people who previously had covid
and um increasing rates of new diabetes
diagnoses certainly public health
infrastructure will assist in not only
screening for diabetes but also for
nutrition and diabetes care and i think
as we consider the menu of many things
that could incorporate be incorporated
into post covert conditions a diabetes
certainly should be one of those
conditions considered secretary of state
and i'll simply add based on what dr
wolinski has said and our scientists are
telling us uh we need to work as
aggressively as we can to make sure that
no american is left behind so that means
that if we need more funding to address
long covert we're going to fight to get
that from congress because we understand
that covet is having effects long after
the actual virus has escaped us
next question please
tamara keith at npr
thank you for taking my question uh by
my very rudimentary math you're getting
about 60
of the money that you asked for for
domestic uh covered uh
programs um so what takes the hit um how
what do you do with only 60 of the money
um additionally um
is there any thought of changing the
requirements of testing for
international travel and masks on planes
if we could get an update on that
okay on your second question uh no there
are no plans to change uh the
international travel requirements at
this point
um we asked uh your math uh good math
here we asked for
22.5 billion dollars
and congress is working to pass
10 billion only a fraction
of the immediate need
and that immediate need is immediate
it's for vaccines therapeutics
and tests
the 10 billion for domestic efforts fund
some of these urgent needs but we still
need additional funding
for both our domestic effort
and our global efforts where there's no
additional funding in the 10 billion
dollars so
every dollar we requested is critical to
both our domestic and global response
hhs under the secretary will
work through how to best deploy these
very limited resources to satisfy the
most urgent of the urgent needs
um and you just we need we need congress
to pass the 10 billion and then get
immediately back to work
to get more money for domestic and get
money for our global response
next question please
who is zeke miller with ap
um thanks um two questions uh
first with the lack of the
coveted funding for international
vaccine sharing um
what impact will that have on the u.s
capacity to share in terms of the number
of doses immediate international
commitments
um through the end of the year and and
then for the doctors you have any update
on
plans and timeline for
pediatric vaccines for kids under five
thank you
so i'll go first on on the global and
the impact on not having any funding
additional funding at this point for the
global response look the lack of global
funding has real implications
on our efforts to vaccinate the world
without the additional global funding
usc usaid does not have the resources it
needs
to help countries get more shots and
arms we'll be
forced to scale back the work that we do
to provide oxygen and other life-saving
supplies to two countries that need them
our global genomic sequencing
capabilities will fall off and that
undermines our ability to detect
emerging variants beyond our borders and
speaking of borders as i've said you
know the virus knows no borders and it's
our national interest to vaccinate the
world
and protect against any possible future
variants so it's a real disappointment
to not have any global funding in this
bill it has real implications we need
funding as quickly as possible congress
needs to act with urgency to fund our
global response so we can accelerate our
efforts to turn vaccines we do have
vaccine supply we need to turn those
vaccines into vaccinations
around the world
uh dr falchi
yeah with regard to the vaccines for
children i believe you're referring
to where are we with the six months to
five-year
vaccine
approval or emergency use authorization
as you well know two companies
have submitted or are submitting data
to the fda regarding children's of
various ages including within that
cohort
of six months
up to five years the data are being
analyzed right now and we're very
sensitive to the fact
that many parents out there are waiting
for a decision on this and the message
we have to them
is that we want to make sure that when
you're dealing with vaccines for anyone
particularly for children
that we get the data we look at the data
and when i say we i'm talking first the
fda for the authorization and then the
cdc for the recommendation
so that we know that they're safe and
thus far
there has to be appears to be no safety
signal whatsoever that would get anyone
worried and the question is what what is
the right dose
and the dose regimen and that would
likely be different for the two
companies that are now involved in
putting their data in
so we ask people to please be patient
because when a decision is be made
you can be sure that it's a decision
based on the good science that's being
collected and analyzed by the agencies
involved thank you
kevin
next question
couple more questions let's go to sharon
law for near new york times
thank you very much um
uh this is a question for dr wilhelmski
please um so last week you said that the
option of the second booster was
especially important for those 65 and up
and 50 and up with underlying medical
conditions so does that does especially
important mean that you recommend it or
you encourage it for those population
groups and you do not recommend it or
encourage it for say healthy people 50
to 65 and if if it doesn't mean that can
you give people some clearer sense of
how they should decide whether to get
the second booster
since many people don't have doctors to
consult with
yeah thank you for that question so we
have made the um the fourth shot the
second booster available to everyone
over the age of 50 because everybody
does have uh individual uh you know risk
assessment as to how they're approaching
this vaccine but we really would
encourage people who are over 50 who
have underlying medical conditions those
over the age of 65 to go ahead and get
that next shot and also to recognize
that they may very well need another
shot come the fall and that'll be the
subject of an fda meeting
discussion tomorrow
kevin last question
josh wingrove at bloomberg
thank you very much can you talk a
little bit more about the announcement
on the pediatric vaccines are you able
to provide a number
and is the fact that they're essentially
sort of subbing in
for uh adult vaccines uh we've seen uh
janzaki speak to this but also kovacs
that demand is waning in uh developing
countries for the adult vaccines is that
the reason
why you're essentially swapping or is it
more a case of you wanting to hold back
a little bit more adult vaccine just in
case we need more widely forced shots in
the u.s and just in case congress
doesn't deliver more funding thank you
so josh good questions i mean these
these donations are part of the billion
pfizer
doses that we previously secured so this
is international supply this has nothing
to do with our domestic supply where we
do have enough vaccine supply
for the booster doses the fourth doses
that dr fauci and dr wilsky just talked
about that have been recently authorized
both for immunocompromised people and
for people over 50. on the domestic
front we do not have
sufficient supply if the science
dictates that all americans get boosted
sometime later in the year or if we were
to need a vaccine-specific
variant sorry sorry a variant specific
vaccine a different formulation than
what we have today we do not have the
funding for that so on the pediatric
international
there are plenty of doses available for
adults which gives us the opportunity
to provide 100 million or more doses of
pfizer's vaccine for 5 to
eleven-year-olds to donate in the
upcoming months
as i mentioned uh 20 countries have
already asked including pakistan and
vietnam have made requests to vaccinate
their children they get vaccines to do
so none of this will undermine the
position that we have right now which is
that we have plenty of supply
in the u.s to send abroad and other
countries around the world to do the
same to make sure that we have plenty of
vaccines for adults across the world so
we are now able to help lead the world
in vaccinating both adults and children
in those countries that are in need
so before we close this is likely my
last briefing i just want to say it's
been
the honor of a lifetime to serve in this
role
as we enter
this new moment in the pandemic i can't
think of a better person to hand the
baton to
than dr ja
i want to thank the secretary
dr fauci
dr welinski for your partnership and
continued leadership and i want to thank
the covet 19 response team here at the
white house
everyone inside and outside of
government who has worked together
tirelessly in our fight against the
virus and
finally and importantly to the members
of the press as always thank you for
joining these briefings
asking the questions you asked
and most importantly thank you for all
the important critical work you do to
provide information to the public
so bottom line thank you
you